- So we're out here today in Hollywood
trying to figure out what this thing is.
Now, people are calling it a hoverboard,
but it has wheels, so...
What is this?
Yeah, what up?
Yeah, what is this thing I'm on right now?
- What they call a hoverboard.
- It's a, some kind of roller,
a new electronic roller skate thing.
- Nice.
- Perhaps just like the movie.
I'm from Brazil, in Brazil we call
(speaking Portuguese)
- Would you call it a hoverboard?
- No.
- Why?
Why is it called a
hoverboard? It doesn't hover.
- Yeah, I don't know.
- Yo, what would you call this right here?
Got it.
You think this is the future?
- I love it.
- This? I hope not.
- So, we're back at BuzzFeed
and we didn't get any
answers on the street
so let's see what people
say around the office.
Yeah.
Hey, what would you call this thing?
- A hoverboard?
- What is this?
- That's like one of those
segway, hoverboard...
No! Yes.
- It's a segway that doesn't have
a handle for your arms.
- They're not actually hoverboards.
That's, like, a complete ripoff.
But they can call it a hoverboard.
- Then what is it?
- I don't know. It's like
some roly poly thing.
- So here's what I learned guys.
This could be called a roly poly,
a segway without handles, or probably
just an interesting way to get around.
But all in all, it's just the future, man.
- Um, a hoverboard with a wheel.
- This is a hoverboard with a wheel?
- (laughs) I don't know.